yeah I mean you can fake it too make it
in a lot of areas particularly if you're
working for somebody else but at the end
of the day if you're going to be great
at something you've got to make the
effort to be great at something whether
it's Sports whether it's physics math
science business whatever it may be you
know it's not just a natural skill
you've got to to learn and particularly
if you're in the technology industry
because it changes every day you know
when I got started I was a bartender
when I first came to Dallas got into the
PC industry got fired started my own
company but I learned early on that
there was always something new and most
people didn't put in the time to learn
it it's like now with artificial
intelligence lots of people talk about
artificial intelligence lots of people
talk about machine learning and neural
networks not a lot of people are putting
in the time to take classes or do the
tutorials or to learn how to apply it to
business and that's what it takes and
you know that's just something I've
always enjoyed so I've been fortunate
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because running the
business is hard and waking up every day
and getting to work when you're all by
yourself is hard and the thing that
saved me that continues to inspire me
motivate me give me hope inspiration
ideas is looking at the stories of
people who've done a lot more than me
and I learned strategies I get
motivation and it gets me to believe in
myself to go off and attack the day and
so I hope this video inspires you to do
the same as well so today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only Mark Cuban enjoy
you may not be a leader to anybody more
than you know the two people who work
for you but it's still a responsibility
and I think
um as you gain more success however you
define that
um being a leader becomes more and more
important how you define success becomes
more and more important what you're able
to do and the impact you're able to have
becomes more and more important where I
am in my life at this point
um it means trying to accomplish things
that I've dreamed about but was never in
a position to try to accomplish or
succeed at and and that's what I'm
trying to do now you've said that
business is the ultimate sport yeah it
is explain what you mean by that you
know in basketball you play 82 games
plus the playoffs you know who you're
going to play you have time to prepare
there's an off season you get some time
off in business you don't even know who
your competition may be and you're
competing with them 24x7 by 365 by
forever you know if I start a business
and you're in my industry I'm coming to
kick your ass yeah and if you start a
business and you're in my industry I'm
coming to kick your ass right and so
that's why I keep on you know investing
in companies starting companies whatever
it may be because that competitive side
of me that's where the Juices Flow yeah
and it's just that ongoing non-stop
intellectual challenge to be great at
whatever industry I'm in that's doesn't
always work yeah but yeah but your goal
is yeah yeah 82-0 in business either so
everybody thinks they know like what it
means to like be an entrepreneur or be a
businessman but it actually feels like a
very specific thing when you really
think about it to be an entrepreneur
yeah yeah yeah yeah how would you
describe it you've got to be willing to
be all in right you know some in sports
you can be athletically gifted right and
that'll carry you a while and then you
know if you want to be one of the top
450 it's not only being athletically
gifted it's you know what's your skill
set and how do you work on it and what's
your basketball IQ and business is very
similar except that it's ever changing
you know we talk about you know three
three-point play and analytics change
basketball some and you know less than
the big man whatever and business is
changing every day yeah you know there's
some new technology there's some new
approach there's some new rule there's
some new tax law whatever it may be so
the rules are are always changing and so
you've got to be curious you've got to
be agile you've got to be able to sell
you've got to be able to communicate
you've got to be empathetic you've got
to be considerate you got to be nice
there's all these different skills that
come together to be good as an
entrepreneur anybody who's working and
getting paid by the hour is going to
have a challenge when something goes
wrong right right do you lose a job does
the dishwasher break does somebody get
sick
is it more than your deductible or you
know or if you haven't covered your
deductible yeah can you cover your
deductible if you're getting paid by the
hour it's hard to save money I don't
care if it's five ten dollars an hour 15
or 50 an hour it's a difficult position
the only way that people really acute
improve their wealth is by buying a
house condo whatever it may be owning
shares a stock and so I think that's
where you start to change the rules also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video yo the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there the first question you're going to
get asked when you go to apply for a job
whether it's now or some point in the
future is what did you learn what did
you do what skills did you add during
the pandemic of 2020 and I think it's
imperative to anybody looking to to get
a job to really push themselves forward
to do better than their parents to
really place a focus on learning you
know I I think you'd agree Mike and
anybody watching that one of the
greatest skills that we all can have in
the in the business world out is a
thirst for knowledge just being excited
about learning and knowing how to learn
and this really is the best opportunity
ever for people to add to their skills
whether it's taking a Coursera class or
you know in the past I would have said
reading a lot of books but now Having
learned from my kids going on YouTube
and you know watching
um tutorials and watching videos on
various subjects you know I learned how
to write a three-letter three-layer
JavaScript neural network on YouTube and
so there's a unique opportunity now for
you to add skills particularly in areas
like artificial intelligence that are
going to be in great demand that most
people have not yet learned because you
know it's it's so recent that it's
become really applicable my dad did
upholstery on cars my mom um did
whatever odd jobs
um but my dad was always like if you
want something you have to earn it and
to his credit he never said no you can't
do that so whether it was selling
garbage bags baseball cards stamps
whatever it was he never held me back
and so I think that was as important as
anything and you know sometimes being
young and trying things you're so naive
and you don't know any better all you do
is learn and if you fail it doesn't
matter and so whether I was 9 10 12 16
21 the failures were irrelevant and you
know whether you're you know 9 12 16 21
22 24 you know I'm sleeping on the couch
you know I have a car with a hole in the
floorboard you know I'm I'm living like
a bum and like a student and so what did
I have to lose and so I think that
influenced me as much as anything so you
know my dad if I go for it you know
don't why not what have you got to lose
you know you have to sleep on a
different couch now let's pretend that
you're just about to graduate from
college right what's the advice
um you don't need the perfect job you
know
um part of the problem is you probably
have a hundred thousand dollars of debt
right
um and you got to pay off for all that
um
and that's really up it's hurt
the economy it's hard you it hurts
everybody but
um my advice general advice is assuming
there's not just the bills you got to
pay that are just enormous it's
you paid all that money to learn now
here's your chance to get paid to learn
and you don't need the perfect job you
need to get a job where you can make
some money
but also where you can learn and add it
to your portfolio of knowledge add it to
your foundation because
as much as we want to think that we know
exactly what our mission in life is and
what our chosen profession is going to
be at 22. hell no there's just no chance
that the 30 year old or even the 25 year
old is going to look back at the 21 or
22 year old you and say oh that dude had
it all together knew exactly what was up
right he's going to look back and go
beer pom what were you thinking you know
and so it don't expect to have all the
answers and don't try to get the perfect
job go out there and get paid to have
different experiences and it's okay to
jump from job to job if it's not the
right job you are getting paid to learn
flip it and then use that to build your
knowledge and learn more about yourself
learn how to learn in business and see
where it can take you how do you
identify what's next
you know I I just read a lot right I'm
just one of those guys that just
consumes information on the Internet or
where everything yeah everything
anywhere I can get I just try to learn
you've always been this way yeah yeah
I've always been like a knowledge geek
where it mostly Tech but it could be
anything not just anything business
related technology related marketing
related you know um culture related I
want to try to stay on top of it you
know Steve Steve Jobs had this this one
quote that really stuck with me he said
everything's a remix and if you look at
the early days of the Apple products
there was this company back in the day
called Xerox Park and Xerox came out
with the first Mouse driven PC
but their marketing sucked and they had
no idea what they were doing no one knew
what they're about Steve Jobs gave me a
little bit of this a little bit remixed
and Bam right all of a sudden you got
apple and then a Macintosh and then
they're yeah he made it sexier yeah and
then even he got fired right he got
fired from that company and then they
had to bring him back to make it work
and so you know for me the more you
learn the more you know how to remix and
that's what this is all about so you
know how do you go from YouTube which
was the first platform for video that
got big to Instagram to Snapchat and
know okay do I want to be on Discover do
I want to be on reels do I want to be on
Tick Tock you know and if I do this you
know how's YouTube going to treat me and
all the decisions you guys you guys have
got to make on a daily basis you know
and the fact that like we're just
talking you created all these products
and you wanted to be organic that's a
business decision too and then you have
to learn by trial and error right you
were curious about what might work you
know obviously you know you're walking
proof of what does work right and now
you've got to be able to continue to
make those decisions because in this
business with all the margins on these
projects everybody's coming at you all
the time right yeah and they think they
can do the exact same thing but it's not
that easy but for me it's like that's
why I try to stay ahead because whether
it's artificial intelligence whether
it's VR whether it's crypto whether it's
metaverse all these things may not be
prime time yet but I want to know when
they will be and I want to be out front
when they when they are the thing about
no matter what you're doing whether
you're trying to be a bartender and
learning drinks whether you're a sales
rep
um whether you're a programmer whether
what you know your consult whatever it
may be
information now is available to
everybody and you know the common phrase
knowledge is power and acquiring that
knowledge is just effort
going out and connecting to people and
learning is just effort and the one
thing I have all these stupid sayings
that you know but the one thing in life
that you can control
is your effort
and that's 99 of the time that's the
difference between being successful and
not being successful who worked a little
bit harder
when you walk into a room to sell
something or to be sold or to try to
understand something or to deal with you
know a problem with your kids or
whatever it may be education
who worked harder that's typically who
worked harder at learning that's
typically going to be the person who has
the advantage in the situation because
we've all walked into situations where
we weren't as prepared as we would have
liked to be or we thought we were and
somebody knew more
that's the king the one thing in life
each and every person in this room can
control from now to ever more is your
effort what is your one personal
characteristic that has helped you most
in your entrepreneurial Journey
um I'd say two one I'm super competitive
I hate to lose and two I'm Relentless I
mean I'm I'm the guy I mean I remember
my first company micro Solutions
I'd buy a bucket of ribs and we we did
the system integration and I wrote
software I buy a bucket of ribs and that
ribs I would just eat as I would suffer
as I would write software and I'd be
there and all of a sudden it'd be 36
hours later you know
um or I'd lose track of days just
because I just get so focused and so
involved in it
um that that's what I do and and and you
know I still you know I I read the
Hadoop manual and and learned a little
bit about Pig Latin and I just want to
keep up right and so that that's
probably my biggest strength you gotta
sell yeah because the in my experiences
the the CEOs the owners the founders
that didn't sell they all failed yeah
with no exceptions a hundred percent of
them failed and you know when you're
just starting and it's just you who else
is going to sell nobody
and that's the other you know and that
leads to another mistake entrepreneurs
make they they try to hit hiring home
runs right so when the minute they hit a
roadblock I'll just hire a you know I'll
hire a new marketing person right or
I'll hire a new head of sales
um hope thinking that oh this person's
amazing no one's ever hired somebody and
said they suck really bad of course
right oh I found the most amazing person
why did they leave the last five jobs oh
they were amazing but right
um that's such a good point see that's
what I love how your brain works it's
like exactly it's so true it's so
practical and common sense it's
pragmatic yeah right common sense but
Common Sense isn't so common no I know
you know you just ask why why'd they
leave you know but but entrepreneurs
tend to think okay I'm hiring this
amazing marketing person and he or she
is is going to know what to do yeah and
then they tell that to their investors
because that's typically why they're
hiring a marketing person and they say
oh this person's amazing you know our
next quarter is going to be great then
it's not then they go to the next
marketing person you know then they're
in this hamster wheel again and they're
screwed and it's so we're relying on
other people well yes and that's the
whole thing right you you've got to be
able to solve the problems yourself
self-reliant now you know at some point
your business gets bigger and you have
to learn how to do a lot of other things
you know when you go to five people it's
one thing you go to 10 or 15 it's
another challenge you know as you learn
how to manage and deal with people but
at the same time if you're not great at
your core competency how are you going
to train those people right how are you
going to know what the the goals are for
the organization how to communicate to
them how to do what you need them to do
when I got to Dallas I was a bartender
at night and I moved in one of my
buddies from Indiana said you got to
come to Dallas and I'm like I'm there
you know my car would only get so far I
had a Fiat x19 with a hole in the
floorboard that guzzled oil every 60
miles and I went down there and there's
a place called The Village it's the
world was the world's largest apartment
complex we had six guys in a three
bedroom apartment I didn't have my own
room I didn't have my own drawer I
didn't have my closet I had a pile and I
had one ratty towel that I stole from
motel 6. and that was it and so I was
looking for my career got a job at a
software store and I was you know I was
didn't have a tech background so I was
teaching myself all this because the way
I look at Tech is somebody invents it
and everybody else is tied for second
place and the ability to learn it and if
if I work harder and faster to really
dive in if it means reading the manual
you know just diving in then I can get a
head start I was 24. and so sleeping on
the floor working in a software company
you know learning learning learning
learning learning getting better at what
I was doing and then one day because I
was dying to get out of that rat hole
that I lived in
um I had a chance to go out and close
the sale for that would have got me a
1500 commission and so I went to my boss
his name is Michael humeki and I said
boss what are my responsibilities was to
sweep the floor wipe down the windows
and open the door to open the store I
got the sale you got to let me close the
sale he goes no you got to be in there
to open the store and I'm like Michael I
mean no so I made the executive decision
to go out pick up the check thinking if
I hand this guy a fifteen thousand
dollar check of course he's going to
change his mind
fired me on the spot and so here I was
living in a show excuse my French you
know just this ratty place with a Motel
6 towel sorry Motel six
um and and really didn't know how I was
going to get out but I went to I decided
okay I'm a lousy employee I went to
um one of the companies that I've been
talking to architectural lighting and I
said look
um I need 500 to be able to buy the
software you want and I promise you that
even if it doesn't work I will wash your
car you know I will walk your dog I
don't care what it is I will do whatever
it takes to make it up to you and they
gave me the 500 and that allowed me to
create micro Solutions and you know six
months later I was out of the Rat Hole
and my company turned into a real
company and that's the one I sold for
six million dollars when I was 29 30
years old I describe myself as a grinder
um you know I just like we talked about
learning that's a grind but I love it
you know and I just
I think
I've just learned what I'm good at and
learned to focus on those things and and
try to
you know utilize those those skills to
now you know not just be an entrepreneur
but probably more often now invest in
and help other entrepreneurs what's made
you successful I have all these stupid
little sayings that I tell myself all
the time or tell employees or whatever
and one of them is the one thing in life
that you can control is your efforts and
I always worked my ass off
always you know first and last out I
went seven years when I started my first
company without a vacation
um I lived like I was broke because I
was and obviously today I still do
um
yeah I don't know why me in terms of why
I'm here and somebody else isn't but
I've always just tried to bust my ass
and be smart about it and I'll keep
learning and trying to improve how do
you fight the fear to take the risk
you don't you accept it and you use that
as motivation I can't even tell you how
many times I was terrified you know when
I first started my business Barbara's
right you know when you're broke you've
got nowhere to go but uh I was sleeping
on the floor eating mustard and ketchup
sandwiches I had nothing to lose and so
you know and I was terrified that look
if I didn't make my next sale my
business was over and that just kept me
going because I didn't like sleeping on
the floor I didn't like gaining 30
pounds because the only place I really
ate anything was going to a bar buy one
two dollar beer and eating thirty
dollars worth of fried mushrooms and
that motivated me just to keep going and
going and you know that that fear is
going to be inside of you no matter what
I don't care where you are in your life
you are going to be afraid at some level
and you just got to keep on working and
part two to that is if you do the work
and you're prepared that's what builds
confidence to overcome that fear and
work through it in Ratatouille the chef
says anyone can cook do you believe Mark
Cuban than anyone
can be an investor and an entrepreneur
um yes of course I mean I think we're
all inherently entrepreneurs it's just
you have to find the thing that you're
good at so you can be a successful
entrepreneur and what would you say in
addition to luck is the best
most valuable trait that can really help
someone survive effort
yeah for entrepreneurs it's effort
because it's non-stop you don't know
what to expect you don't know what
tomorrow is going to be you know your
business may be crushing it and then
somebody makes a mistake on the term of
their notes at Silicon Valley Bank and
the next minute you go from I'm on top
of the world to how am I going to make
payroll that's the nature of being an
entrepreneur there's nothing that AI
won't impact as big as the so having
been around a while I saw the impact of
PCS then I saw the impact of low query
networks then I saw the impact of wide
area networks then I saw the impact of
the internet then I saw the impact of
mobile then I saw the impact of Wireless
you know now I'm seeing the impact of of
artificial intelligence and it dwarfs
any of those things and if I don't
understand how to apply it to my
businesses I mean I remember selling PCS
and software and walking in saying you
don't need to use that pen and paper on
on a you know on a notepad or a ledger
pad now we're going to give you a
spreadsheet and by the way here's a
here's a spreadsheet that costs 495
dollars and I had to pay to go get
trained on how to sell it which is crazy
crazy now when you think about it but
then we said okay now you can play what
if then we said you can connect these
PCS unless I understood the technology
how was I going to explain it how was I
going to understand unless I understand
it now how am I going to invest in it
you know then I got to go trust somebody
who says oh yeah I know Ai and maybe
they do maybe they don't and it's really
easy just to have just to okay so you
figure it out that's just not my style
so you're building a base of knowledge
and then you think that at some point
it's going to pay dividends in terms
already has right I mean if if you truly
believe AI is going to change everything
how are you going to understand what
people are doing to change everything
unless you at least have a foundational
understanding of it now I'm not going to
build a million layer neural network and
try to change the world and I'm not
going to show you I'm not going to write
a research paper and saying here's how
why the lottery ticket approach works
and you can build smaller neural
networks with less data um and be more
you know resource efficient but I can
read that stuff and understand that when
when somebody says okay we're building
this project and we need this size data
set or this size data set we need this
amount of resources I can ask questions
and understand the answers the same
thing I told myself the same thing I
tell everybody one you're 21 22 23 years
old right you don't have to figure it
out right now
don't try right you spend all this money
sorry
um
paying to learn now is your chance to
get paid to learn you don't need the
perfect job you just need to go
somewhere where you'll learn
and start to be exposed to different
ideas and now it's not like you know
when when Greg 40 years ago was
graduated
and me five years ago
you know it was like get a career and
you know the pressure was get a career
go work for IBM or General Motors and
get a pension those days are gone people
can't even pay their pensions anymore
and so you're a free agent
and you're always going to be a free
agent on the market you guys are the
Kevin Durants and LeBron James you know
where you're always out there and can go
find a better situation for yourself do
what's best for you what have you got to
lose like when I started my company you
know after I got fired by Michael umeki
um
um you know what was how bad could it be
I would lose my Motel 6 towel you know
it was just like what have you got to
lose and yeah I understand there's
pressure from student loans and there's
a lot of conversations we can have there
right but you know you can get a job
that doesn't have to be perfect you can
learn at that job and you guys have the
pedigree you have the brains you have
the initiative to go out and try the
next job you know you know the good news
is the economy is good enough that it
may not be perfect but you can go job to
job don't look for the perfect answer
just look to get the experience look to
learn because all these different
exposures all the different things you
learn learning how to learn
that's what's going to give you get you
excited and juicy for for something that
you love because once you find something
you love to do
that's when the magic happens
because when you're when you're able to
find something you love to do then you
can start work focusing on how can I be
great at this and like Greg found out he
was a great networker I like to you know
play with technology and try to do
things first you know whatever it is
that you find about yourself then you
can try to be great at it and it's rare
when people quit things they're great at
you know and so trying those things so
that that's how I advise people don't
don't stress just go out and try
different things there's a shark game
Tank Company from last season called
mush right cool stuff it's like this um
oatmeal that they packaged it's fresh
dried oatmeal that they packaged with a
little spoon and you it has to be
refrigerated but you just grab it and go
and the the response was great from the
show and now like I just saw their
numbers they went from 50 000 in sales
to a hundred thousand to 125 000 in
three straight months it's not scale but
they're growing right and they all of a
sudden like okay we got to go raise
money and we got to do yada yada right
scale is hard not just because of the
economic cost but also because of the
people cost and the mind share cost it's
hard when you're dealing with a major
comp and in particular if you're dealing
with a big company like a Walmart or
Costco or whatever because you only get
one shot of those guys and so like I
told mush with Whole Foods
they're interested I'm like you're not
ready
you're not ready you have got to you've
got to crawl before you ball you know
and
and and and and so
I told him it's going to be painful not
to go after that big customer
but think about what happens if you go
after it and a it's going to take
Capital you don't have and you're going
to borrow it or B it doesn't work out
and they return it all then all of a
sudden you're out of business and so
you're you're right that you need
Capital to scale but you also need
the confidence that you can scale and
that you can keep your customers happy
and so I always tell people get to the
point where you have you you've taken
care of the customers that you can take
care of once you can demonstrate that
then you can get smart money and you're
talking from a position of power and
then you can go to the Walmarts of the
world the Costcos and you may not even
have to raise money they may even
provide po leverage or po support or
connect you with a bank that does and so
I guess I guess what I'm saying is
don't get too far ahead of yourself
because sometimes sales can be a lot
more expensive than you think they are
and you've got to be careful I've seen
several my Shark Tank companies try to
get too big too fast and then almost put
them out of business we're partnering
with a lot of Independent Pharmacies so
that we won't just be mail order and
we'll start a test on that March 1st and
the goal is again to allow patients to
get their medications how where when
they want them at a price they can
afford so do you think that that basic
model of a transparent set markup works
for Branded drugs yes absolutely you
guys know selling manufacturing and
selling generics the distortions you
face with pbms and insurance companies
the fact that an insurance company wants
you to price your generic at even
sometimes above a brand price is insane
it is just absolutely freaking insane
and we're just going to say that
sorry you know there's just not going to
happen and
um it's just it's not about the patience
anymore and so you've got these big
companies that are vertically integrated
that have hundreds of subsidiaries that
play left pocket right pocket you know
we're going to be an accumulator we're
going to be the switch we're going to be
this and they own and they take a little
piece here and there and then they do
everything they can to distort the
information chain right we're not giving
you your own data about your own medic
the drug you manufacture so for brands
that there are so many games that have
to be played unless you have you know a
unique drug like keytruder like we were
talking otherwise you're you're at the
mercy and what's happening is they the
the pbms in particular have done a
phenomenal job of demonizing all the
manufacturers generic and brand now
every patient in the world thinks you
guys are the bad guys
brand manufacturers they're the bad guys
that's wrong not that they're you know
harmless they're not that they always do
things right
but it's just wrong that you've been
demonized like that that's why
transparency is so important because no
patient is trying to find the net effect
of drug price that you're being paid to
say who's the bad person in all of this
they just want to know what their cost
is what their availability is and what
Hoops they have to go through well now
you just look it up brand or generic on
Cost Plus drugs.com you know what our
cost is two you know it's not the
manufacturer that's creating the problem
because here's the price that they're
selling to Cost Plus that and so for a
brand name it's even worse for them than
it is for you and so we want to solve
that problem and then in terms of
support that the patient gets with hubs
the games that are paid you know just to
get information back is insane you know
it's like people forgot about the
patient we want to make it easier for
you brand manufacturers to be able to
say to anybody that comes to you go to
Cost Plus drugs you see what they're
paying us you see that this is the right
price
and you can trust it because that really
is our biggest product that's what we
truly sell at Cost Plus drugs and that's
trust my biggest regret was I wasn't as
nice as I should have been you know
um
in my mind I didn't suffer any fools
right if if you if I didn't think you
were using common sense then I would get
annoyed and no one liked to be around me
when I was annoyed and for me it was
just like faster faster faster faster
the Train's speeding up how fast can we
go
um that was a huge regret that I would
do over again
um
I think with the Mavericks when we had
our problem
um
with sexual harassment and I wasn't
there to oversee it I thought by that
point in time I wasn't you know I like
today I didn't go into the office ever
and so I missed it and it hurt a lot of
people and and and that was awful
um
so I'd say you know those two things are
probably the low lights in my career the
best money I ever spent was when I
bought a lifetime pass on American
Airlines right after I sold my first
company I got really really inebriated
with a bunch of my really good friends
and they were all like what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do and you know I'm not a
fancy guy as you can tell you know I'm
not into this and that but I like to
travel I like to have fun and I bought a
lifetime pass on American Airlines for
125 000 which let me travel a hundred
thousand miles I think a year for the
rest of my life so if today if all of a
sudden I turned 20 years old with 20 in
my pocket and this crazy year 2020 could
I be successful again the answer is yes
and I'll tell you exactly what I would
do I'd get any job any job at all that
allows me to pay my bills doesn't matter
what it is because now I know I can
learn from anything that I do number two
now that I have a little bit of a tech
background or a lot Tech background I
teach myself to do Amazon Alexa and
Google home skills most a lot of people
have Amazon Alexa in particular and they
know how to use it generically but they
don't know how customizable it is so I
would just like I did back in the days
when I started micro Solutions and I
went to all these different retail
stores handing out my business cards
saying if you ever have questions or
need help with PCS and computers I'm
your guy I would do the same thing now I
have a question for you do you think
that like people like because I also
know that you kind of came from from
nothing just like your family yeah you
weren't handed anything no nothing do
you think it's harder for people now to
reach the level of success that you have
because
um because of a saturation no no I think
it's easier you think it's easier now I
think it's easier I mean look at you all
right you all have good idea good
connection to people right just went for
it and when other people might say you
do a b and c or you should do a b and c
you did d e and f right and found your
angle and you know the only thing that
can stop you is would it work worker you
know was it a good idea or not and
that's the thing like you have so many
tools like back in the day you know you
had to buy these big computers and you
know it was more expensive now you get a
laptop or an iPad and you get an
internet connection and you can have any
technical companies right now I think
social media too and I mean look what
we're doing now right we're doing this
and you're gonna have it up on YouTube
and streaming it and millions of people
are going to be able to get to it yeah
and it's not like you're spending
millions of dollars like a TV show or a
movie would have been 25 years ago right
it's actually easier now on one hand the
tools are are cheaper and more
accessible the other hand there's more
competition how do you do all of this I
mean honestly like your schedule between
the Shark Tank Shark Tank all those
companies doing like these things I mean
like what time are you waking up in the
morning six five thirty six like what's
the date like give me a day you probably
should admit this but like I'll get up
at 5 36 particularly during the school
year my kids are going to school you
have three kids yeah 12 15 and 18. yeah
are you involved all do you see these
kids because how are you able to do all
I don't travel that much unless they're
all doing stuff really right now my
middle daughter Melissa is at Camp my
wife and my youngest son Jake who's 12
are in Iceland right now they went on a
trip because while I'm shooting Shark
Tank that's when they all know to go do
their trips that's a good idea yeah and
then my oldest is on a trip as well so
with her class and so all you know so
while we're shooting they're gone and so
that's when I pack everything in and
then you do everything yeah but
otherwise you know I can do one day
trips here one day trips there because
you know I'd rather spend time with my
family so you so you are like you spend
a lot of time with your yeah of course
yeah that's the best yeah that's the
best part of my life okay so tell me
give me your daily you wake up at you
said six o'clock yes wake up yeah 5 36
do you know say hi to everybody because
everybody going to school if that's
what's up and um then do my email and
typically get back in bed do my email
get through any emergencies go back take
a nap what's the worst idea you've ever
had so like right out of school I got
fired from a job and then um I was
trying to come up with something to sell
and it was powdered milk and it was just
I'm like well people need to save money
on milk so you know if it doesn't taste
quite as good no I learned the hard way
that didn't last a week
um
what other have I up
I mean it's just you know I'm like
everybody else still right it's just
like you'll think of something yeah and
you'll start thinking about it and then
you'll Google it right and you'll see if
it's out there
it's not no one's done this before then
you'll tell your guys or your friends
like okay that's not bad getting a
little traction now a little extra
confidence but then you got to try to
actually get someone to buy it right and
that's always the hard part and what
people forget you know when you go out
there and start googling and it's not
there there's a pretty good chance it's
because they went out of business right
and it's already been there but um yeah
I've I've had plenty plenty of bad ideas
um but that's okay man you know like I
tell everybody you only got to be right
once yeah that's no one no one remembers
like how many times I screwed up you
know just gotta be right once I never
ever thought in terms of money okay I
need to make millions I always thought
in terms of time has always been my
driving motivation how can I control my
own destiny how can I control my own
time I started a company called micro
Solutions and from there we just grew
and grew and grew and ended up selling
that and that's how I got my first
Stacks so here's the rundown of when I
sold micro solutions for six million
dollars so a million dollars went to
employees two million to a partner I
brought in 2 million to me I live live
like a student but the first thing I did
was my lifetime pass on American
Airlines and I just went all around the
world taking friends and partying like a
rock star other than the air pass
I wasn't just buying I was saving it I
could have gone out and bought a bigger
house bought a nicer car
I didn't care would have bought me was
freedom I never thought I was going to
work again I've made a ton of money in
the stock market I was worth 20 plus
million dollars life was good then one
of my buddies from college Todd Wagner
sat down with me and this was in 1995.
he was like you know there's this whole
new thing called the internet there's
got to be a way we can use this to
listen to Indiana basketball we set up
this website called audionet and the
next thing you know video comes along
and we turned it into a company called
broadcast.com and so we started what
turned out to be the very first
streaming company on July 18 1998 we
went public and we're guessing you know
what what's the stock going to open at
and I was the high I'm thinking 33
dollars
those
62.75
all of a sudden I'm worth 300 million
dollars plus
and I'm sitting there thinking
oh if this stock price triples
I'm a billionaire well we took that
company and became the biggest media
portal on the internet and Yahoo came
along and made us an offer and all of a
sudden that stock price tripled
and I was a billionaire let's just say
if we put 10 guys here you'll interview
them okay you could within a 5-10 minute
interview say this dude's not going to
make it as an entrepreneur could you
pretty much know that you know I'm not
very good at interviewing the issue is
my interview skills more than real I'm
horrible yeah Shark Tank interview well
yeah it is but I get to do due diligence
after the fact right so I get to play my
henches but I get to check yeah I mean I
can I can typically tell right I can
tell
um but by um
their passion I can tell by their focus
I can tell by their preparation you know
there's a whole realm of things in any
business here you know here's here's the
business you're in and here's a thousand
things that influence whether or not
you're going to be successful and really
to me by you know through my experience
in businesses I can put myself in his
position and say okay here are 900 of
the thousand things he has to be aware
of and then go through and ask and by
how many of those or her
um issues they've been able to address
already that kind of gives me a sense of
how hard they're willing to work you
know and I can tell by the questions
they ask me so all I have to do is say
okay what do you want to know and you
know when they start saying what should
I do they ask you yeah yeah and that's
fine right and I want them to ask
questions but you know people like to
say you know the only stupid questions
are the one you don't ones you don't ask
and that's not right right because the
questions you ask tell everybody tell me
tell whoever more about you than
anything else you do because in
particular tells me about your
preparation if you ask me questions
questions about just basic things that
you should have known and you should
have down to a science
that's going to disqualify you almost
more than anything in terms of content
there's never too much content there's
just
because what we want and who we are and
how we consume content
changes every day through our
experiences the challenge of content
isn't can you make it or is there too
much the challenge of content whether
it's business content the proposals you
make what you put on your website how
you connect to people is can you tell a
good story
you know and now storytelling has
evolved it used to be we all congregated
around the TV and there were 250
channels but you know it was the best
alternative to boredom you come home
you're worn up you sit there one hand
goes in the pants the other hand goes on
the beer and you watch TV now all the
content comes to us no matter where we
are there's there's a source of content
and who we are and how old we are and
our experiences that defines what we
like just go to Twitch like I have a
nine-year-old son who plays fortnite all
day every day if we would let them right
and he'll watch Ninja
now ninja is a I don't know if you all
know who he is he's like big guy on
Twitch that streams fortnite games and
um he came to the Mavs practice facility
one day because we got to be friends
just through random sources he was a
bigger star than when Tom Hanks came to
visit I mean and this is a guy on Twitch
now
twitch's unlimited options of content
related to gaming and other things and
they're expanding YouTube obviously just
unlimited content and it's not like
YouTube's struggling where the the
takeaway from all this is when there's
so many options for Content as business
people you have to figure out how to
connect with people you have to know
your audience and you have to know how
to tell a story and honestly that's not
my strength I literally and I forget the
name of the book I'd have to look at my
phone I'm reading a book on storytelling
because that's how people connect we
have so many choices if you can't absorb
us with something that engages us a
story and simplified into a story that
we want to connect with
the next person is going to be who come
the next person is going to come in and
take your business what role do you
think billionaires should play in terms
of making the world better I mean I'm
not going to tell someone else what to
do with their money everybody's got to
decide who they are but I think it
really comes down to how you Define
capitalism you know to me capitalism
isn't about how much money can you make
capitalism means how much impact can you
make you know how if you can be an
entrepreneur and start a company where
do you get your satisfaction and
satisfaction can come from you know how
much money do you have it can come from
you know how much have you changed the
world it can come from you know how have
you changed the lives of seven people
that were important to you you know but
that's that's the beauty of a capitalist
system the the bad side is I think we've
defined it for so many people that it's
just about money you know it's not about
impact and that's one of the reasons I
do shark tank because we send the
message that the American dream is alive
and well and I try I personally try to
send a message that you know a company
can have incredible amounts of impact on
on people I did a deal
um last year with um Eric this company
called No Limits l-i-m-b-i-t-s and she
has a prosthetic leg and she started
creating fashion for people with
prosthetics
it's just you know and it's small now
but it's going to do and every every
single one of her customers she's
impacting their lives and making it
better you see that every time with
businesses and so to her to me and to
many others capitalism is your
opportunity to to use your own skills
and use your own and to grind it in your
way to have an impact and you know
to me that's that's the way to go but
I'm not going to tell somebody else how
to how to go as opposed to the other
startups that have appeared over the
last five to ten years you seem to be
jumping right into some sort of vertical
integration model where our parallel
supply chain I think is how you guys
speak of it publicly of the four
business lines manufacturing wholesale
Pharmacy and Benefit Management which
have you found to be the most
challenging and why manufacturing
um where you know there are a lot of
shortages as everybody knows and so
we're doing um fill and finish
manufacturing
um for short drugs on the shortage list
in Dallas and it's all automated with
robotics and all that and there's it's
always something so we had thought we'd
already be up and running but hopefully
in the next couple of months we'll get
there but that's been the biggest
challenge yeah and which one do you
think of those stakeholders the benefit
management wholesaler Pharmacy and
Manufacturing do you think is the right
best with this for a disruption they're
all dollar they all are they all you
know they all fit together because again
wherever there's pricing Distortion for
reasons that don't benefit the patient
which is there is no pricing Distortion
that benefits the patient then that's an
opportunity for us to disrupt and again
trust and transparency cures all of that
increase your offering what do you think
the barriers are for that I think it
took some time and again thank you to
all of you who supported us at the
beginning but it took some time for
people to think okay it's just a shark
tank guy he's just you know dealt
messing around with this and now people
are starting to realize we're real you
know you know hopefully by the end of
this week we'll have two million
accounts set up
um and growing and the number well
patience accounts people who set up
right right yeah and um lives and so
um in the number of scripts and orders
keeps on growing and coming in and
accelerating and and so you know we're
just going to keep on
seeing where it takes us because you
know again I have the saying when you
run with the elephants there's the quick
and the dead and so we have to be quick
and I don't think we're impacting
anybody else's business in a big way but
we'll get there thinking about the next
big opportunity in the cryptocurrency
space into your credit you were around
for D5 summer D5 was a big opportunity
in 2020. you were early in saying
ethereum and nfts is you know possibly
going to be really big and it was really
big after cryptocurrency finds a bottom
do you have any thoughts about the next
big opportunity in the space it just
comes down to Applications if you guys
got great ideas I'm wide open right I'm
tired of the pictures I'm
getting like new D5 for new you know
there's a great analogy between what
happened in Silicon Valley
um with SAS software and other
applications even like uber right where
tons of money came in and subsidized all
these apps Uber's just now starting to
make money 15 years whatever it is 12
years later you know there's other apps
that same thing and so what happened
with apps like I was an investor in box
and I actually wanted them to just
generate Revenue as opposed to raise
money to subsidize free
um online storage and so um
they went their way they bought me out
and it took them I don't even know how
many years for them to make money
um I'm never a big fan of raising
hundreds of millions of dollars to do
tens of millions in business but that's
exactly what happened in crypto and but
crypto was distorted because people
looked at the token valuations
and so what would happen is they go out
and do a token sale and generate a bunch
of capital or even worse they'd raise
hundreds of millions of dollars from um
VCS and use that money to create a fake
yield right you so we saw that with
anchor right where it was like okay
we're offering you 20 percent
and then they hope that they'd be able
to generate enough loans to cover the 20
percent
never came close
all that yield was subsidized all those
five seven eight ten twenty fifty ninety
100 yields
um have always been subsidized by
investors now with those investors not
willing to subsidize anymore you're not
seeing the crazy yields and you're not
even seeing the inflationary yields
um from the blockchains anymore you know
where you would say okay you know
um if you stake this we're gonna pay you
four percent or eight percent or twelve
percent and they can't even afford to do
that because you know if you inflate too
much there's not enough intrinsic demand
to cover that inflation and your token
price is going to drop and that makes
your investors mad that makes your
speculators mad
and it ignores the fact that to be a
real business you have to be a real
business and crypto doesn't change any
of that covet you have said has changed
the world in terms of opportunities uh
it's obviously hurt people but it's
obviously help people who are
entrepreneurial so you've said this is a
good time to actually figure out new
businesses new areas of business is that
fair statement yeah you know it's so
unfortunate but it's true I mean you
know we've heard Warren Buffett say you
know buy when there's blood in the
streets and it's almost analogous here
so many small businesses are closing so
many you know retail stores are closing
malls are are you know going bankrupt
um companies that are unable to
transition to to selling digitally or or
really taking full advantage of
e-commerce or struggling big companies
don't understand don't really aren't
sure about how to protect our Legacy
businesses that type of uncertainty
creates a lot of opportunity and combine
that with people becoming farmer more
comfortable with purchasing online and
living a digital lifestyle I think
there's a lot of unique opportunities
that are available to people who who are
creative who have a vision for the
future I think you know 10 15 20 years
we'll look back and they'll be 10 20 30
world-class companies that were created
by people who we probably think are
thinking are crazy right about now what
do you do on your free time like when
you can do anything yeah now it's my
kids right my kids are 12 15 and 18 so
I'm at that spot now we're like going to
play one-on-one with my son is pretty
cool just you know my 18 year old
daughter is getting ready to go to
college so just get any of our time is
cool
um and then my middle daughter is you
know is is just unique man she's just
she's crazy and I love hanging time so
that's really like my number one
priority now if it wasn't family and if
it's not business what do you enjoy play
golf I'm not a golfer I hate golf but I
play I play pickup basketball so like a
couple times a week I'll go play pick up
basketball go work out
um you know go hang with my friends
whatever chill but yeah but now you know
it's family and and business and and
working out more than anything else
would you say the number one not to
Pivot that hard but like would you say
the number one reason why people are
failing then is because their lack of
ability to work hard and to kind of dig
in what would it be no I'd say they're
misguided and they sell themselves they
lie to themselves when they start right
oh I think this business is good
everybody goes through that same process
with the new business you know hey what
do you think about this idea right then
you go on Google and you look up oh I
don't see it it's great of course no one
tells you that it's not there because 50
companies have failed doing the same
thing and there's nothing left to show
that they died but you know then you get
excited you check with your friends and
then they try to raise money yeah that's
what screws them up right raising money
is not an accomplishment it's an
obligation yeah you know if at all
possible you want to start just
organically with Sweat Equity those are
the best businesses because you get to
you get to retain 100 of it right you
know and there's no rush and then the
second mistake people make is they push
the Top Line instead of the bottom line
or gross margin dollars yeah you know
it's like Oh I'm a million in sales like
that's an accomplishment or 10 million
where like if you've raised funding you
have your quote-unquote kpis right yeah
right or what is what's new on qoks or
something there's something ridiculous
that um qkp I don't know they always
come up with these actors what is it I
don't know just the one I started seeing
and so everybody's like oh yeah you know
and they think it's an accomplishment if
you're doing I went from one million to
5 million in sales
okay that's somewhat great but what
matters is what's your gross margin
right because if you're in that hamster
wheel where you're growing but you need
to keep on raising money to grow right
no you see what's happening now when
people can't raise money you're done you
know and While others have said well you
know I've you know raised 30 million or
50 or 100 million dollars unless you
have a really good reason you know that
your relativity space and you need to
raise money because you're building you
know 80 foot tall 3D printers yeah right
you're not going to do that out of your
basement but for most entrepreneurs it's
something where there it's an Arbitrage
on their time yeah right here's I can do
this more efficiently than Jan or Mark
can so it's worth it for General Mark to
buy this product or service from me so
that they can use their time more
efficiently I think people will always
stop me and say well I want to start a
business what should I do and if you
don't know you're not ready right you
know you've got to have something that
you're good at and if you're gonna be if
you're gonna do it you got to be the
best at it because I'll tell them look
if I come in and compete with you I'm
going to kick your ass are you ready to
compete with me yeah right and you've
got to work like this someone working 24
hours a day to take it away from you
what are you looking for when you get
pitched like top to I mean you get
pitched on television yeah
in the restaurants yeah
um I look for something that makes me
think why didn't I think of that you
know or it makes me think oh my goodness
that's a good idea and then the
follow-up questions are you know is it
differentiated enough can they protect
it
um what's the unique element and then
the secondary parts of that or not even
secondary the the other part of it is
you know how good an entrepreneur is it
and can I help them and so once you get
once I get past those initial hurdles
whether it's Shark Tank or just you know
people emailing me literally I've
invested well over 100 million dollars
in the companies for people I've never
met to this day interesting I think now
I've really evolved some of my focus to
trying to help disadvantaged
entrepreneurs people who have less
opportunity I just invested with the
woman Arlen Hamilton
um who we've together created a little
million dollar fund where she's going
out and finding 10 businesses run by
people of color or disadvantaged lgbtq
type communities and just opening doors
because I think my my experience applies
to anybody right any entrepreneur no
matter what you're trying to sell and I
also think that it's a great business
opportunity simply because
the markets that they wanted to sell to
are underserved there just aren't as
many entrepreneurs so there's more
opportunity and so I I think it makes
great business sense as well I always
say you know for every one of my
businesses I said what would I do to
kick my own ass you're right so whatever
business you have there's somebody
trying to put you out of business
there's somebody trying to to take a
bite out of your business and it's
better for you to figure out how they're
going to do it rather than they do it
um and so yeah that's being paranoid and
so you have to be paranoid you have to
anticipate other people's next moved and
moves and you can't ever you know
downplay the competition you know I was
telling um I was at a business plan
competition this morning for at a
college and they were kind of being
dismissive of the competition and so you
can't ever do that you know they're out
there trying to take you down and
they're not just going to sit still and
if you're good really really good you're
going to inspire them to work even
harder faster better and so you have to
be you know very self-aware of what
you're good at and what other people are
good at and you know a healthy dose of
paranoia makes them is very helpful you
are a successful entrepreneur before you
bought the Maverick and become
and you know running a successful
business versus running a successful
sports team
um effort you know I've always said the
one thing in life you can control is
your effort a lot of people like we're
just saying a lot of people like to talk
and don't like to do the work I think
salesmanships
um there's never been a company that
succeeded that doesn't have sales you
have to have a product that people want
you have to be nice to your customers I
think nice is underrated
um you know I didn't always I wasn't
always this way but I think over the
last 10 12 years I've realized that just
by being nice you get a lot better
results and people tend to want to work
with you a whole lot more so I've
recognized that sometimes a smile and
you know just
chilling out a little bit goes a long
way one of the attitude I got for my dad
was you know when you're older and you
look back at your life what would what
would be the things that you remember
and think about that when you say yes or
no to doing something that's really
bizarre or really interesting and so
I've tried to take that attitude whether
it was you know buying the Mavs or doing
Dancing with the Stars or if you really
want to see me embarrass myself and look
I have no problem embarrassing myself is
that all my friends will tell you but if
it's something different and just
something bizarre and interesting I'll
do it so if you turn to TNT tonight
there's a show called drop the mic and
you'll see me rap and I am the world's
worst rapper but it was so much fun and
so you know when I'm 90 years old and I
look back and say should I have done
dropped the mic and wrap to look like an
idiot
hell yes
hell yes right because I got this unique
experience where this professional
rapper taught me how to rap and they
gave me all this stuff and I got to you
know battle with Rusev this guy who
wrestles for WWE who's like five foot
eight and four hundred pounds of muscle
and you know who threatened to kick my
ass in our little battle so it was fun
my best mistake and that's a great
question um
probably buying the Mavs everybody told
me I was an idiot and yeah
um just because we were the worst team
in all professional sports and that's
what everybody said and I had paid the
highest price for a sports team up until
that point and everybody said I was a
the the second thing the other
time was after when we sold to Yahoo it
was for 28 million shares of stock and I
immediately colored my stock to protect
it from the downside now this was not
when the Internet stock market was
cratering it was still going up right
and so I colored my stock meaning I
didn't really share and much of the
gains going up and there was a limit to
the gains I shared and Yahoo stock
immediately went up 30 percent and um I
remember going on CNBC and they said
don't you feel bad about losing you know
it's gone up another 80 points and you'd
be worth another 700 million dollars and
I was like
it's tough to feel bad when you're
sitting on your G5 watch and see if
but yeah so coloring my stock everybody
thought was a big mistake because they
thought the market was going to keep on
going up and that's not how it turned
out if you're going to have them run a
business if you don't understand
accounting you're already behind the
eight ball can't you hire a guy that's
that knows they still have to
communicate to you right I mean there's
people that don't understand the the
concept of you know the difference
between profits and cash you know oh
your account might tell you you're
profitable but your cash is going down
you know not understanding
um a breakdown and when you don't
you think you need college to learn that
yeah I think you do right because it may
not for some people look if you're so
self-motivated that you can take an
online course in accounting and teach
yourself everything you're way ahead of
the game anyways but most people aren't
and I'm not saying you have to go to
Indiana I'm not saying go to an
expensive school I don't care if you go
to a community college and take
accounting and spend 99 bucks for the
class just you know
spending the money forces you to be more
obligated to do it but accounting
Finance less extent Marketing sales that
the school offers that these are all the
that's the language of business and so
while it's possible to teach yourself
these things and while it's possible to
hire them when you're starting your own
company you don't want to have to spend
money hiring an accountant right you're
already probably going to have to hire a
lawyer to set up uh your your well let
me take that if you've gone through all
these classes if I don't have to hire a
lawyer to incorporate right you can
probably figure out yourself and so your
cost of opening up a business drops but
even more important and all that that's
that's the blocking of tackling that's
the language of business you know the
thing I learned at Indiana that was more
important than anything else I learned
how to learn and learning became far
more important to me because the one
certainty in business is that it's
always going to be changing the if if
you're not always learning to this
minute if if I'm not continuously
learning if I'm not just absorbing as
much as I can absorb someone else is
going to kick my ass how often do you do
you uh educate yourself a day like is it
like an hour like every day every minute
that everything I do is about learning
more because that's the only way I can
kick your ass you know because I'm not
gonna out athletic you right it's not
about my basketball IQ it's about my my
business IQ right in technology and
business and everything's always
changing if you know five years ago if
someone would ask me about artificial
intelligence I wouldn't know right yet
AI is the most important part of
technology and really business going
forward so if I'm Going to Be an
Effective investor an effective Mentor
an effective you know um operator of
businesses you know even with the math I
gotta understand AI because you know
like with the Mavericks when you know
when you talk about analytics it's
changed so dramatically even over the
last five years going from you know
different types of things per and you
know Advanced RPM and all these
different metrics for basketball to how
do you implement artificial intelligence
and pose estimation and computer vision
and how do you understand all that stuff
to make the right decisions for the Max
and so if I want to be in a position to
make those decisions and not just ask
somebody else to do it I got to learn it
and so I put in hours I do tutorials I
take little online classes and it
doesn't make me an expert it's not like
I'm gonna say you know I could get a job
if I needed to running AI or running
tech for a big company I couldn't but I
understand all the concepts and
understand the issues and how to apply
them to business so if you're going to
be good at anything you've got to stay
ahead of the game and business is the
ultimate sport you know I I used to say
it's a jerk and I always say it to Luca
you know it's like dude you know you
play 48 minutes you know a 48 minute
game you practice a couple hours you go
home and you relax and you play you know
you play Call of Duty you know business
is 24x7 I'm going every day because
there's some 16 year old kid out there
trying to kick my ass in one of my
companies and it ain't going to happen
right and and so I'm that competitive
and I'm that you know I work that hard
at learning to try to stay ahead of the
game Michael Jordan had the body he had
the temperament of a champion so he goes
into sports do you think they call that
bounded rationality instead of saying I
could be every possible thing in the
world you kind of limit it and say all
right I'm more of a math guy oh I'm more
of a people person and then you try to
find your destiny within that well I
think they go hand in hand right because
the type of person you are that you know
kind of points to the things you're good
at are you 12 you're not going to know
are you 16 you're not going to know if
you're 18 maybe if you have a special
talent yeah right you know you can throw
a baseball 100 miles an hour you can
sing and your voice is incredible you
know you're you know a concert pianist
you're a chess Grand Master if you have
a specific skill set or talent that just
immediately propels you to the top yeah
you want to follow that yeah but I
remember having a list I still have it
um when I graduated from college I was
getting ready to graduate and all the
different industries that I thought I
might want to partake in when you you
find something you're good at yeah go
for it yeah and I also also always say
it's not about passion everybody's got
passion for something yeah right don't
follow your passions follow your efforts
because people say you know I was
passionate to play baseball I was
passionate to play basketball it doesn't
mean all of a sudden I was going to be
good enough yeah but I found myself
spending being really curious about
business being really curious about
technology and that curiosity is really
what drove me and I think particularly
if you're young today curiosity is great
always learning and trying to find new
things and being curious about new
things because that's what leads you to
that path trying to figure out in
advance yeah that's hard because you
don't know what you don't know you have
lived your life as an iconoclast and in
a way that's a template for other people
but in a way it isn't so in other words
how much you've got an ordinary person
ordinary man or woman how much of an
Acana class could you or should you be
like Mark Cuban oh I don't care just you
should just be yourself right I mean I
take pride in the fact that I didn't
give a show what anybody thought or said
I just going to be myself and you know
on my dad's son on my mom's son my
brother's brother you know um Alexis
Alyssa and Jake's father Tiffany's
husband this you know I just try to do
the best like everybody else I mean I've
been blessed you know like I say all the
time I'm the luckiest guy in the world
and I just try not to take it for
granted I try to enjoy every minute and
I think now as I've gotten a little bit
older I try to give a little bit more
back than I have before and and try to
help more people and
I you know in terms of whatever if
anybody else finds himself in my
position just enjoy the moment enjoy
every minute of it I mean I guess my
question is are you a role model for
people in society
I don't know I mean I never thought of
it I mean it's not something I try to be
I just try to be myself you know I just
try to to help where I can do what I can
be a good dad and you know I I don't I'm
not trying to be something for somebody
else just myself I'd like to talk a
little bit about failure uh you know
you've had some uh and famously but
you've I think you've been we're fired
from your from early jobs right which
forced you to be an entrepreneur where
there were there any uh failures that
you know in hindsight were just super
valuable and like set you on the path
yeah yeah I mean I learned more from the
places I got fired from and the places I
worked that I hated than I did from the
places I liked you know I learned what
not to do you know I got fired because I
went to close a sale
um instead of opening up a retail store
and sweeping the floor yada yada
um thinking that when I brought back a
check from a closed deal he would be all
excited and he fired me
I learned from that that sales cures all
you know that that company was out of
business not much later yeah and you
know it just taught me so many lessons
about how to deal with things how to
treat people what to focus on and that
led to you know me getting started and
also taught me that you know when I was
living six guys in a three-bedroom
apartment I had nothing to lose nothing
right and so being young was the perfect
time to start a business because what
was my downside you know we taking the
seventh roommate you know it's just like
and so you you know there's so much I
learned from the places where things on
the surface seemed to go wrong but I
learned what not to do and sometimes
that's just as important as what you do
do you've got to go to afworks to see
our afwork team you just got to meet
some more spark tank finalists what what
advice would you give them on Innovation
and how to take it Forward I mean learn
from what you saw up here I mean the
Brilliance of each and every one of
those ideas is that someone's saw a
problem and let me add all of us have
had ideas that we thought were going to
be the next great thing right we we get
that feeling in our stomach oh this is
going to be amazing and then you talk
about it with your friends or who you
work with and they say what a great idea
and then most of us stop
what you saw up here and what made it so
compelling is that they didn't stop
there weren't complicated Solutions
right I mean some of them were Advanced
technologically or they were super smart
but they were simple in that they they
just took basic problems and they tried
to solve them
there's nothing that's that's something
each and every one of us can do and so
the best advice that I can give you is
do it
you know when you have that idea when
you have that opportunity
do it because that's what separates the
people that
just separates the entrepreneurs or the
entrepreneurs
from everybody else they just took that
first step
Don't Be Afraid take that first step
what's the worst thing that can happen
innovate be agile because we're all
going through a reset and you know like
I say all the time we're going to look
back in 10 15 years and there's going to
be 5 10 20 50 companies that are world
class game changers that were created
because of this pandemic why can't it be
you why can't it be your company why
can't you change the game you know your
competitors are struggling as well and
even if you're competing with larger
companies who maybe can work on smaller
margins or maybe you can work on smaller
margins because you're leading me
they're worrying they're worried about
protecting their legacy businesses you
know they can't be as agile as a small
business can and that's the other point
I'm making innovate and that Innovation
doesn't have to come from the top again
when you're talking to your customers
when you're talking you know when you're
talking to your employees who may be
talking more to your customers ask them
for ideas on how you would do things
differently because every CEO every
entrepreneur goes through that thought
process prior to all this where they say
if I only have had the time I would do a
b or c If I Only Had the Time I would
redo my marketing materials my website
whatever if I only had the time I would
redo my supply chain or if I only had
the time I have all these new ideas I'd
like to try now you have the time now is
the time to do it Now's the Time to be
agile Now's the Time to innovate you
know one of my favorite things is when
you run with the elephants there's the
quick and the dead and now you got to be
really really quick because the
elephants can't run at all they can't
dance and so this is a unique time a
unique opportunity got to be great at
something it's not just about being good
and doing your job and getting through
the day and not creating any problems
it's about what can you be great at and
that's where the effort comes in now
you're not there's you're not going to
just be able to pick and choose and be
great at it I couldn't be great at
basketball or hockey or a lot of
different things right so you've got to
try as many different things because
like I said before doesn't matter how
many times you fail
you just got to be right one time that's
it one time so if you're you're busting
your ass in the mail room and that ain't
it what are you doing at night what are
you doing the weekends what can you make
that you can sell to other people what
is it that you can buy that you can sell
to other people what is it you can sell
online what is it that you what service
that you can offer can you go and teach
Alexa how to do skills and go towards or
whatever it is you've got to find that
one thing you can be great at build a
business around that bust your ass and
it's possible don't stop looking for a
job now right just because things are
difficult doesn't mean you know that
there's not opportunity there because
all it takes is one if you just if if
you grind it out and you continue to be
persistent whether it's emailing calling
you know setting up on seminars whatever
it may be however you can connect with
people applying for jobs wherever
however do it you know every no gets you
closer to a yes and all it takes is that
one opportunity to propel you to where
you look to be and you know and I guess
adding to that
again like I said earlier there there's
so many new things going on when you
know when I came out of college way back
when
um the was the last time that
unemployment was in double digits you
know my friends you know I remember
reading the story I went to Indiana
University talking about how the
unemployment rate in Northern Indiana
was 20 and you know my friends were
freaked out like kids are today and I
had to be mobile right I had to go from
Indiana back to Pittsburgh my home down
to Dallas in order to really get to a
job that that I could platform and so as
you look for these things
you you really have to be more
adventurous if you will and be more
mobile and be more flexible and agile
and and that's not necessarily a bad
thing you don't have to get the best job
you don't have to get a perfect job you
just have to get a job and now all of a
sudden you're getting paid to learn and
you can platform that just like an MBA
free agent right they might spend one
year or two year at one two years at one
team build their skill set to get better
and go to a better situation looking and
finding a job looking and finding an
internship looking and building your
skill set to prepare yourself for what
comes next there's no better opportunity
than now do you think there's a proven
formula that if a brand rookie guy he's
got a lot of Ambitions got out of this
route but not a lot of knowledge on how
to do you think if he follows a formula
he's guaranteed to make it as an
entrepreneur no no no okay so you don't
believe there's a guarantee to make it
no because who knows who you're going to
be competing with so if you put two two
people both following the same formula
both in the same industry right which
one wins you know maybe they both can
win and both be successful but you know
so I don't I don't think there's a
default default template for success but
I think there's things that you can do
to put yourself in the best position to
succeed you know so I talk about stuff
in the book you know I talk about the
one thing in business you can control is
effort uh you know um going out there
and sales curing all you know so I I
think you know and I agree with your
point that there are things that if you
do them you put yourself in the best
position to succeed but you know if you
just walk into a buzz you know a buzz
side somebody else is doing a little bit
better you know what happens there's no
we live in a day and age where you can
start anything do anything and
you you shouldn't put limits on yourself
I think everybody's here because they
don't believe there are limits on
themselves and that they can get out
there and do anything and I like to
point to myself look if I can do it
there's there's a lot more people out
there that can do it and you guys should
never let anything hold you back you're
talking you know alluding to earlier
about entrepreneurs being born or built
you know and I think there I knew I was
wired to be excited about business how
or why I don't know but you know and
there's certain guys that have the
genetics to jump out of the gym right
for certain guys you know that you know
when they golf they have the muscle
memory and and the discipline you know
dirt
um the whiskey may not be the most
talented guy in the NBA but his
discipline and his Focus to do what's
necessary to be successful he's willing
to do and combine it with being seven
feet tall and being skilled you know it
makes him an amazing basketball player
so it's understanding what your skill
set is finding the right place to use
those skills and then going for it you
know will that make you 250 Grand it
depends if you pick the right industry
but whatever industry you pick if you
outwork everybody if you try to be a
little smarter than everybody if you try
to be a better sales person than
everyone if you try to be better
prepared than everybody you've got your
best chance because if you don't do it
and somebody else does
you know I have the same work like
someone's trying to take it all away
from you you know work I actually work
like someone's spending 24 hours working
24 hours to take it all away from you
and that's kind of the way I look at it
I get that question all the time so what
industry should I look at I can tell I
can tell you all about artificial
intelligence computer vision
personalized medicine
but then what right and so the and maybe
you're an expert in one of those fields
and you can go for it but what I I tend
to try to tell people in terms of what
does it take to be successful find
something you love to do and then be
great at it not average
not marginal not good enough but if you
can be great at it be great at it if you
are the the greatest videographer in the
history of videographers
people don't care about cell phones
what is it that you can do that makes
them know that what you the way you do
it is special
and if you can do that and convey it
then you'll be fine if you're not sure
then you know you've got it you've got
to decide whether you want to stay on
your own get it you know be a contractor
or go work for somebody you know it just
depends you know and let me add one
other thing
I crushed myself
um and like my brothers didn't they they
took a completely different path and
they were looking just nine to five at
yada yada not everybody's got to be an
entrepreneur and so if you if you've got
it in your blood and that's what you
want to do then find a way to be great
and if not you know you'll figure it out
you'll find something else I started my
first business when I was 12 I was
buying and selling um baseball cards
buying and selling stamps anything I
could do to make money I was hustling
and trying to do so I was in the
business but I not so much where it was
all my friends were into it with me so
they wouldn't know
baseball cards yeah baseball cards you
name it I mean I grew up in Pittsburgh
and so I would probably even less than
12 years old I would
excuse me go up buy a bunch of baseball
cards that I collected and I would
package I would say okay you're
guaranteed to have a Pittsburgh Pirate
in this package and I would charge three
times as much and I'd set up on this
park bench down in the park down in
Scott Township where I grew up and um
I'd have these little sails and it was
great I made money and I mean it was you
know and I learned as much about
business when I was 9 10 and 12 as I I
learned any other time you almost have
to have that drive like in other words
you can't fake it you can't like pretend
that you want to read about Ted Turner
and okay I'll Skip One movie
your soul yeah I mean you can fake it
too make it in a lot of areas
particularly if you're working for
somebody else but at the end of the day
um if you're going to be created
something you've got to make the effort
to be great at something
um whether it's Sports whether it's
physics math science business whatever
it may be
you know it's not just a natural skill
you've got you've got to to learn and
particularly if you're in the technology
industry because it changes every day
you know when I got started and and you
know after I got I got it I was a
bartender when I first came to Dallas
got into the PC industry got fired
started my own company but there I
learned early on that there was always
something new and most people didn't put
in the time to learn it it's like now
with artificial intelligence lots of
people talk about artificial
intelligence lots of people talk about
machine learning and neural networks not
a lot of people are putting in the time
to take classes or do the tutorials or
to to learn how to apply it to business
and that's what it takes and and you
know that's just something I've always
enjoyed so that I've been fortunate of
that what industry you
requires a lot of innovative
Innovation look
one of my dad's favorite sayings was you
don't live in the world you were born
into everything changes all the time and
you know what's better than change
creating change and so whenever I see
something that's done the way it's
always been done you know like when I
got to the NBA you know my whole goal is
just F things up right because data
everything was done the exact same way
they thought they were in the business
of basketball
for 50 years they thought they were in
the basketball business no when you go
to a basketball game you don't remember
the jump shots the dunks remember who
you were with the fun you had it's one
of the few Industries where that ball is
in the air at the end of a game
everybody holds their breath and you're
if it goes in you're hugging people
you've never seen before you you know so
you can take any industry and look at
the way things have been done and try to
come up and innovate and you know and
like I said with just the nature of
capitalism right now all the changes
that are required
every industry needs change and there's
a unique opportunity that I don't think
any generation's ever seen
how do you know like is it a gut feeling
when you like when you're investing in
somebody to say I think they can do it
or like yeah I mean I can tell I've done
I've done this so many times that
um different people have different
qualities you know the fight they've
been through but you know and really
it's not just the fight but it's how
little they talk about the fight you
know I have a rule that the longer the
back story the worse the investment so
there are there's a lot of people been
through a lot of challenges and a lot of
difficulties and they want to tell you
about it right and that's all they want
to talk about whereas with Arlen you
know I got a glimpse of our backstory
but she started talking about the
company she's investing and why and you
know she knew what she was doing and
more importantly she was able to give me
access to entrepreneurs that I couldn't
get access to on my own and that really
was the Clincher do you have a favorite
shark tank behind the scenes story
because there's some oh there's so much
there's so many of them
um most of the time so Shark Tank when
you come on they might last anywhere
from 30 minutes for a stupid deal to 60
to 90 minutes so in real time they go on
forever and a lot gets edited out and
there's just times particularly Lauren
where she'll say something and didn't
realize that it's completely
inappropriate and so you know because
she just doesn't think that way and so
if you complete double entender and so
one time she'll kill me for saying that
um so one time we had
we had um a vitamin company and I hate
vitamin companies on Shark Tank because
they make all these claims any
supplements right
and so they came on and it was spray and
the guy's sitting there and he goes you
know a lot of people have problems
swallowing vitamins pills right so we
created this this
um spray she goes I have no problem
swallowing and we said
God you committed you know
and then you know her husband's back in
the back laughing and then she it dawned
on her like you just pulled so just
those types of moments are Barbara you
know or or Kevin too Kevin you know we
like to pick on Kevin a lot because he's
kind of a one-trick pony with royalties
and Licensing you know but but there's
times when he's got a really great heart
he tells great stories would you um tell
us what do you think is next for you
I just have fun you know somebody's got
to be the luckiest guy in the world and
and I think it's me you know and I don't
want to look back and say well why don't
I do that why didn't I do Dancing with
the Stars
um why you know why didn't I do shark
tank why didn't I do this why didn't I
do that I just want to experience it and
experience with my family and you know
and and just compete and have fun and
learn and just see where life takes me I
don't have like here's the one more
thing I have to do or here's the bucket
list thing I have to every day of my
life's a bucket list you know and
I mean I I don't want I just want to
enjoy it first time you put your name on
something Mark yeah it's Cost Plus drugs
company first time ever all right tell
me why why put your name on this company
because it's 2023 in the United States
America and there's still people who
have to choose between medications
rent and food and that's insane and so
when you start looking at the industry
and start asking why uh
it goes back to the it's such an opaque
industry where there's zero transparency
and it's funny because we started this
um four years ago but only actually
launched 13 months ago and a lot of it
was because the farmer broskreli right I
was talking to my partner yeah right cut
yeah
um and so I was talking to my partner Dr
Ash mayanski and I was like look if this
farmer dude can increase price of 7 500
that means there's got to be such a
market Distortion going on we should be
able to cut prices in the same manner
and so starting with generics we've gone
out and put together an inventory list
so far of 1100 skus but the key to it is
transparency so when you go to
costplustrugs.com and you put in the
name of your medication whatever it may
be example
um so a matinee right which is a drug
for chemotherapy
um and so you put in a matinee and the
first thing that comes up is our cost we
show you exactly what we pay for it then
we show you our markup which is 15 then
we show you what we charge for the
pharmacy what to pay the pharmacist
right the filthy and then the shipping
because we're initially we're mail order
that's it you see exactly exactly what
we pay our markups you know exactly what
it is and because of that Simplicity of
transparency our pricing is in some
cases insanely less so with the mat nib
before we got in this business if you
were prescribing mat nib and like you
know how it typically goes when you get
a prescription from your doctor doctor
says you need this medication right who
survived because you're getting
chemotherapy right and just it could be
anything right and then the next
question is what pharmacy do you use yep
it's not this is what it's going to cost
it's not and the crazy part is even the
pharmacist doesn't know what they're
going to charge you until you show up
and you show the prescription oh hey and
then you're like oh this I thought this
was covered right and and so for the in
the case of a matinee people were
getting charged more than two thousand
dollars for a life-saving for a
life-saving medication we've since we've
had a bunch of price Cuts I think our
price now depending on the strength is
12 dollars wow wow which is which is I
mean I I rarely want to use this word uh
but that's sinful it is sinful you know
it's insane and it's only because the
entire healthcare industry but
particularly Pharmaceuticals
is opaque Nobody Knows the actual cost
of anything because you made it this far
morning video I want to celebrate you
most people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want to learn about money
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there start young the
big thing about it is we started
building this little snowball on top of
a very long hill so we started a very
early age in Rolling the snowball down
and of course the snowball the nature of
Compounders versus it behaves like a
snowball